[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim militär des
jahres wir zeichnen ja in vier
kategorien die angehörigen des
österreichischen bundesheeres für
besondere leistungen aus sowie die
sonderkategorie der miliz in dieser
folge geht es um kategorie 2 die heißt
zivilbedienstete des jahres hier kommt
für sie ein überblick der nominierten in
alphabetischer reihenfolge
nominiert als zwiebel dieser des jahres
sind bernhard krenn mit der entwicklung
eines unterkunftsgebäude sin
nachhaltiger holz modulbauweise kann er
das erste bauvorhaben im bundesheer mit
klima aktiv standard gold auf die beine
stellen andreas stummvoll seit ausbruch
der cobit 19 krise erstellt er täglich
eine europakarte mit der zahl aktiver
cupid fälle diese findet auch
international beachtung und wird zum
beispiel vom sanitätsdienst der
deutschen bundeswehr übernommen
herbert völkl weixler super beginnt 1997
mit dem aufbau einer bio kompostierung
am übungsplatz kronberg die dem
bundesheer hohe entsorgungskosten spart
1999 erhielt er den umweltschutzpreis
des landes steigern
wer wird zivilbedienstete des jahres das
verrät uns jetzt der stellvertretende
kommandant der streitkräftebasis
privateer siegfried bodner
wenn es hier werden beim hin und her im
österreichischen bundesheer sind rund
15.500 menschen beschäftigt der großteil
von ihnen als soldatinnen und soldaten
aber wir haben noch viele
zivilbedienstete die uns im täglichen
dienstbetrieb wertvolle unterstützung
leisten
ich freue mich heute einen dieser
zivilbediensteten der mit seiner arbeit
außerordentliches geleistet hat mit dem
award auszeichnen zu dürfen wie vor die
spannung hierdurch zu groß wird darf ich
ihnen den gewinner bekanntgeben
es ist uns anfällig der ingenieur
bernhard grimm vom militärischen
immobilienmanagement zentrum an
strategien ist in diesem bereich für
spezialaufgaben zuständig unter seiner
führung wurde in österreich weit
einsetzbarer prototyp eines neuartigen
unterkunftsgebäude es entwickelt das
besondere ist die nachhaltige holz
modulbauweise die durch ihr gut sehen
system eine erhebliche verkürzung der
bauzeit begrüßt möglicher flexibilität
garantiert diese nachhaltige bauweise
verbunden mit dem einsatz regionaler
ressourcen ermöglicht es so das erste
bauvorhaben im österreichischen
bundesheer das dem klima aktiv standard
gold entspricht
gerade in zeiten des klimawandels und
der nachhaltigkeit setzt das
militärische immobilienwesen mit der
entwicklung eines gold zertifizierten
bauvorhabens ein sehr eindrucksvolles
zeichen zum schutz unserer umwelt und
der gleichzeitige ressourcenschonende
bauweise
hauptverantwortlich dafür ist ein zurück
der ingenieur bernhard grill die auch
dafür verantwortlich zeichnet das die
neue sicherheits schule rechtzeitig zum
schulbeginn in einem provisorischen
betrieb gehen konnte
und der derzeit mit der umsetzung der
barrierefreiheit und der notwendige
sicherheitsmaßnahmen in der rossauer
kaserne befasst ist ich gratuliere als
stellvertretender kommandant der
streitkräftebasis hier in ein strikter
ingenieur verändert grant sehr herzlich
zur auszeichnung zivildienst oder des
jahres und dafür persönlich alles gute
wünschen sehr geehrter direktor kein
lieferten hat es ist mir eine freude und
ehre die ihr den preis für den
zivilbediensteten des jahres zu
überreichen
[Musik]
ins theater des jahres bernhard klenk
geboren am 27 september 1983 absolvierte
erfolgreich unter anderem die htl
bautechnik hochbau in wiener neustadt
wird planungs und baustellenkoordinator
und schließlich projektmanager geplant
war das alles eigentlich nicht mit dem
ursprünglicher wunsch wäre es eigentlich
gewesen tischler zu werden das einfach
mal und aus dem einfachen ausprobieren
ist eine vielzahl an handfesten
projekten entstanden wie zb die
unterkunft in holz modulbauweise
das ist wirklich das besondere an diesem
projekt das ist okay ich hab eigentlich
kommt leute was drin sein der sein
einkommen und ich bin gerne da den
wohlfühlfaktor in den liegenschaften des
bundesheeres deutlich zu erhöhen ist
bernhard grenz großes ziel beim
bundesheer ein lebensprojekt ich hoffe
ja das ist vollkommen korrekt und es
soll ja auch sein dass wir das projekt
das wir das ja oft machen ist ja auch
das ziel davon
die bdp verweise zu machen also strikt
wiederholt wo man natürlich auch aus
erkenntnissen dann lernen kann und wenn
wir sagen wir bauen das jetzt in der
kaserne in feldbach das erste mal ist es
so wie sonja allem egal wissen wir haben
ja sicher bürgerwehren und damit
künftige bauvorhaben den tatsächlichen
bedürfnissen noch besser anzupassen und
darauf zu reagieren
ist dann die kunst dass wir sagen okay
wir haben ein fertiges fix fertiges
konzept es ist auch hier der
hintergedanke davon einfach sagen okay
vielleicht braucht der nutzer jetzt mein
zimmer sondern er braucht vielleicht ein
zwei mann zimmer wer braucht vielleicht
auch einzuziehen aber wie auch immer
dann haben wir das auch in der lohn- und
dann können wir schneller und
effizienter darauf reagieren
bei allen erfolgen die bernhard grimm
vorweisen kann hat er allerdings eines
nicht vergessen nämlich wie es ist auch
zu scheitern
es wird dazu unbedingt unbedingt also
ich bin oft gescheitert und die wäre da
sicher noch weiter hinauf scheitern
das ist mir vollkommen ja wo es ist
wichtig ist heute dann wieder aufstehen
und sagen okay
blöd ist passiert ist man kann es
anwendern man mochte das nicht
absichtlich wer so denkt der weiß auch
erfolge wie die auszeichnung zum zwei
bediensteten des jahres entsprechend zu
schätzen
es ist die anerkennung ist wirklich die
anerkennung dass man sagt okay herrschte
so sich leiste man man sieht dass man
jetzt nicht nur intern als abteilungs
intern oder oder amt sind dementieren
sondern es geht auch weiter zieht
weitere kreise und das ist natürlich
schon ein tolles gefühl
dass man dass man das über diese
anerkennung genießt
[Musik]
herzlichen glückwunsch bernhard kleinen
zivilbedienstete des jahres in der
nächsten folge geht es um die
sonderkategorie miliz bis dann
[Musik]